Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
[ All cheering ]
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
[ Bell dinging ]
And tonight,
Silicon Valley veteran
and self‐made billionaire
investor Chris Sacca
joins the Tank and goes
head‐to‐head with Mark Cuban.
Mark, you're not making
any sense at all, man.
I'm making total sense.
No, no, no, you're not.
‐How stupid are you?
‐Look, look.
I know this is going over
your head ‐‐
Shut up and listen.
No!
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
Don't be mad at me
that I understand
this better than you.
[ Scoffs ]
Narrator: This is "Shark Tank."
No, you've
got it wrong, Chris.
I sometimes wonder how you
made all that money.
‐Ouch.
‐Whoa.
♪♪
First into the Tank
is a multi‐use accessory
for new moms.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Melanie Disbrow,
and I'm from Allen, Texas.
My company is Milk Snob,
and I'm here today
asking for $125,000
in exchange for 5% equity
in my company.
Almost all new parents
use some kind
of infant car‐seat cover,
but the conventional
blanket and canopy covers,
they would not stay put.
Mm‐hmm.
My kids would pull on them,
and they would fly off
in the wind.
[ Cuban laughs ]
‐Wow.
‐Been there.
[ Laughs ]
Disbrow:
This is the Milk Snob cover.
It fits on any infant car seat
within seconds.
It is breathable,
and you can peek
at your baby any time
without waking
their precious slumber.
It's super soft,
which is great
'cause it's also
a nursing cover.
So, when you're ready
to breastfeed,
you just take it off
and you put it on.
It gives you 360 coverage,
it's breathable,
and you can nurse confidently
in public,
wherever you go.
When you're done
nursing your baby,
you just take it off
and you put it back
onto the car seat.
The Milk Snob cover
has become a must‐have
fro new parents everywhere.
So, I'm asking you, Sharks,
who of you must have me
as their partner?
[ Laughter ]
I'm just gonna
pass out samples.
Melanie, I would think that
the best part about being a baby
would be to see
where you're going.
No? In a carriage?
[ Laughter ]
You can actually adjust it
and you can lower it
down the handle...
Thank you.
... which is really great.
I appreciate it.
It feels great.
How long has
the Milk Snob been around?
What are sales
gonna be this year?
We've been selling this
18 months...
Yeah?
... and we made $1.2 million...
That's good.
... in sales.
‐Wow.
‐I didn't expect that.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
‐[ Chuckles ]
And where did you sell?
Was it all online?
I only advertise
on social media.
I've actually seen you online.
My wife showed me ‐‐
you were in the Facebook
"Little Mamas" group.
Yes.
When this showed up
on "Little Mamas,"
she literally showed me,
and I was like,
"Yes, that.
I've been dying for that."
Is social media
your background?
No, social media is not
my background.
Actually, I'm from Germany.
And I met my husband,
he was in the military,
so I move with him
to the United States.
And I did not really
have the time ‐‐
we had children,
you know, on the way.
And so I couldn't go
to college.
So, when my son was born,
I actually taught myself
photography.
What do you sell it for?
I don't think
you mentioned that yet.
We sell it retail for $36.
‐Wow.
‐What's your cost?
What does it cost you?
So, the cost is $7.60.
And everything
is made in Dallas.
Good for you
for manufacturing in Dallas,
in the United States.
That's awesome.
Yes. In the last five months,
we made $800,000 in sales.
‐Wow.
‐I love this story.
That's amazing.
What a surprise.
Dallas, baby!
[ Laughs ]
Why are you here?
This is one of the more
successful businesses
I've ever seen.
I'm here because
I'm looking up to you guys,
and, actually,
I'm a horrible public speaker
and I pushed myself
just to meet you guys.
And I'm just so happy
that I'm here
and I want to take this
to the next level,
because we also got approached
by bigger retail stores,
so I would need a great partner
who just lets me know,
"Melanie, you have to do
this and this."
Look, I'm blown away.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you 125K
for 8% of the company.
‐8%?
‐Say yes.
Say yes.
That is
a really great offer.
My wife
is my investing partner.
We work from home
together
while raising our three
daughters together.
I literally am
a driver of that device.
I mean, the only contingency
in my offer
is that I get to take
a couple of these home
with me tonight...
[ Laughter ]
... because
I need them now.
[ Chuckling ]
Yeah, yeah.
You know what,
I'm gonna go out,
because I think
that's a great offer.
Yeah.
I really like
what you're doing.
I'm gonna give you
125K for 10%.
And the reason
I'm doing 2% more
is because the value that
I bring to it is worth it.
I'll give you $150,000
for 10%.
Oh!
I'll raise the bid.
Oh, come on.
Yeah. It's my offer.
I can make any offer I want,
Chris.
I don't need your guidance.
And I'm gonna
clear the deck.
I'm not gonna make you
an offer, so I'm out.
You have three offers.
If I go home tonight without
owning a piece of this company,
I'm gonna have to answer
to somebody, so...
Well, then pay her more.
... let's figure out
how to do this deal.
He's got tons of money.
Ask him for a lot of cash.
See, what I was starting
to say ‐‐
Lori definitely has
some incredible skills.
Right?
‐Okay.
But she's not hanging out
on "Little Mamas" right now.
She doesn't know some
of the social‐media channels
you're using to generate
some of this awareness.
I don't know
why he's saying that,
'cause he doesn't know me
very well, but that's okay.
Look, look, QVC's amazing,
but they still
sell VCRs there, okay.
I'm not just QVC, which
tells you how little
you know about me.
"They still sell VCRs."
I like that.
So, you need to do
a little educating.
So, Lori, would you
go down to 8% equity?
How about if I give you $150,000
and I keep the 10%?
I think
she just copied my deal
because she has no creativity,
unfortunately.
[ Laughs ]
‐Is it possible ‐‐
‐I like the 10%,
because I really want to be
working hard for you.
Okay.
And I know what kind
of resources
I would put behind you.
Well, here's
the funny thing ‐‐
Absolutely.
I would love to do
a deal with her,
except I learned
my lesson last year.
He holds a grudge.
That's not a good thing.
I don't want
to pre‐empt her.
I think there's value
she brings ‐‐
I've been trying to say this
for a few minutes now.
Would you join together?
That would be ‐‐ make my dream
come true. [ Chuckles ]
It would make so many
of my dreams come true, too.
I've been dying
to work with Lori.
[ Laughter ]
But 5% is nothing.
Okay, so, if you joined,
how would that look like?
Well, you make us
the joint offer right now.
You're gonna have the benefit
of two Sharks,
and so there's got
to be more equity.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Melanie has three offers
on the table
for her car‐seat cover,
Milk Snob.
But she wants Lori and Chris
to partner together,
so they've asked her
to make them an offer.
Sacca: You're gonna have
the benefit of two Sharks,
and so there's got
to be more equity.
[ Sighs ]
How much equity are you
willing to sell?
I work so hard
for this company,
and I don't want
to give up more than 5%.
But you can't get Sharks
interested in 5%.
The highest
that I would go is 10%.
So, if you guys
would split it...
When you take
a product like this,
I feel you need
to blitz the market.
'Cause what happens
with products
is people
get knocked off.
‐Yes.
‐It just happens.
So, you need
to blitz fast.
I understand you don't want
to give up more than 5%,
but I think 10% is worth it
to the Shark.
So, your offer
was 10% for ‐‐
I went to $150,000
for 10%.
Okay. And you, Chris?
I'm out.
I'm out, too, 'cause you're
not even talking to me, so...
Okay, so...are you sure?
I don't see you having
the flexibility on the equity
that it's gonna take
to make us both interested.
♪♪
Lori, you actually
were my pick,
so I would love
to accept your offer.
[ Chuckles ]
Good.
‐Yay.
‐Good.
Yay.
Disbrow: Thank you.
We'll blow this up.
Yes, thank you
so much, Lori.
It's great,
it's great.
Thank you.
‐Be proud.
‐Yes, thank you.
Can I buy this one
right now?
Yes, yes.
I'll hook you up.
Okay, thanks.
Cuban: "I'll hook you up."
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations.
♪♪
Disbrow: I'm so excited that
I partnered up with Lori.
Our sales are gonna skyrocket.
It's amazing.
Narrator: In season 7,
Mike Doyle and Drew Mitchell
made a deal with Mark Cuban
and Chris Sacca
for their event‐based
home‐rental business,
Rent Like A Champion.
10% total for 200K?
Correct.
We would love
to do the deal.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Doyle: Today,
we're in Auburn, Alabama,
just blocks from campus.
We're at
a Rent Like A Champion home,
and it's game day.
We're throwing
a huge tailgate party,
inviting homeowners
and potential renters.
The best part is
Mark and Chris are coming down
to make the event
even more successful.
‐Whoo!
‐Yeah!
Cuban: We're out here
in Auburn, Alabama.
We promised our guys
that we'd come out
and tailgate with them,
so here we are.
Sacca: You know, this is one of
my first deals on "Shark Tank,"
and I was actually on
the verge of going out,
but these guys kept selling,
and I'm so glad they closed me.
When do we get
to $10 million in revenue?
I think
next year's the year.
Doyle:
The year before "Shark Tank,"
we did $2.3 million in sales.
Since partnering
with Mark and Chris,
we've done $5.46 million
in total rentals.
Mitchell:
Mark just really stepped in
to help us
focus on our business
by taking back‐end operations
off of our plates.
At Chris' urging,
we've been looking for
new markets to expand into.
We are now official partners
with six PGA golf tournaments,
providing
private home rentals
for players, caddies,
and tournament sponsors alike.
All right, who's ready
to watch some football?
[ All cheer ]
Our business started
with a small problem.
We never had any idea
that we'd have the opportunity
to go on "Shark Tank."
This has absolutely
been a dream
and a life‐changing experience
for the both of us.
Sacca: Look,
I've seen what it looks like
when a company goes from zero
to tens of billions of dollars.
These guys have that same kind
of vision, grind, hustle.
They know they're
just getting started.
All: Rent Like A Champion!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a kid entrepreneur
who wants to help other kids
fulfill their
entrepreneurial aspirations.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jack Bonneau.
I'm the founder and CEO of
Jack's Stands & Marketplaces,
and I'm
from Denver, Colorado.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Steve Bonneau.
I'm Jack's dad.
I work for Jack.
Sharks,
I'm seeking $50,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
I'm 10 years old,
but when I was 8 years old,
I really wanted a LEGO set,
but it cost $400.
The good news was,
my dad said I could have it.
But he'd have to pay for it
with his own money.
So I did what most of you
probably would do ‐‐
I started
my own lemonade stand.
After 12 weeks,
I made $900 after expenses...
Wow.
... learned some
valuable lessons,
and, yes, I got
my LEGO Death Star.
[ Laughs ]
The experience
is exactly why
I created
Jack's Stands & Marketplaces.
Jacks's
Stands & Marketplaces
provides kids
and their families
opportunities to learn
about entrepreneurship,
business,
financial literacy,
while having fun
and making some money.
We provide everything
except their mood
and their enthusiasm.
Jack's Stands offers kids
the opportunity
to sell lemonade
and other drinks.
We offer kids
the opportunity
to sell more
than just lemonade ‐‐
Jack's Marketplaces
provides young entrepreneurs
the opportunity
to sell their products
in authentic
and great marketplaces,
and have kids sell
those great products
and tell
the inspirational stories
of these
young entrepreneurs.
So, Sharks, our challenge
and question to you is ‐‐
Who wants to make money?
While inspiring our nation's
youth and entrepreneurship.
So, Jack, tell us about
the actual business.
I have seven locations,
where the other kids
operate my stands.
I'll teach them how to greet
and serve the customer,
how to make ‐‐
Is this all in Denver?
This is all in Colorado
right now.
And where are they located
in Colorado?
So, we have two locations
in a mall,
and then we have five
other locations in
farmers markets and ‐‐
Jack, the mall locations ‐‐
how much do you pay in rent,
and what is your revenue
from those locations per month?
The rent's
on a percentage basis,
so it's 15% for the mall,
and the revenues to date
is approximately $15,000.
‐Per stand?
‐$15,000 total.
That's the two stands
in the mall?
Two stands in the mall.
And how many months
have they been in there?
Nine months,
approximately.
Nine months.
This year, we're gonna
expand into 12 locations.
This year, we're projected
to do $150,000 in sales.
Good for you, Jack.
Way to crush it, buddy.
Thank you.
$55,000 of that
is from my stands,
and $95,000 of that
is from my marketplaces.
Next year, we're projected
to do $1 million in sales.
[ Laughter ]
So, Jack, in order
to know you're profitable,
you have to keep track
of all your numbers.
How do you keep track
of all your numbers?
At the end of the day,
we'll go through
a mini
profit‐and‐loss statement
to figure out the kids' revenue,
expenses, profit, and tips.
So, what do you do
to help Jack?
Right now,
I'm behind Jack 100%.
I had my own company,
that was a modest success,
but the journey
that we've been on
for the last
three years ‐‐
working with the kids,
seeing Jack grow ‐‐
it can't be beat.
Cuban:
If I wanted my daughter Alyssa
to set one up in a local mall,
what would I pay you ‐‐
or what would she pay you?
The kids get between
10% and 15% commission
of all the sales.
The kids would show up,
and Jack would
show them how to ‐‐
But I'm gonna be
in Dallas, right?
You're not gonna just
have people in Colorado?
Well, we try to find families
that are championing a location,
and Jack would come down
and teach those kids
how to operate
the stands.
Let's get serious, now,
'cause $50,000 is not
a small amount of money.
I love the story.
I love entrepreneurs.
But I want them to be full‐time
when I invest in them.
I don't want you
to drop out of school.
I want you to finish
your education,
then come back to me.
But for now, I'm out.
♪♪
Sacca: So, let me
ask you a question.
Where'd you get the money
to start this business?
So, my parents
loaned me $1,000
just for the first stands,
the supplies,
and then
for working capital,
but I've since paid
my parents back.
I've also gotten other loans
from Young Americans Bank,
a great bank in Denver.
My first loan from them
was $5,000, and then ‐‐
‐What?
‐Yes.
Are you serious?
Steve:
Young Americans Bank
is the only bank
in the United States
that solely works with kids.
Hey, Jack, have you
paid back the $5,000?
We're currently
60% paid off.
What's that
monthly payment like?
Um, it's about $250.
Jack, you're incredible.
I mean...
[ Clapping ]
One of the reasons
I do this show
is to inspire
kids like you.
I hope my kids,
millions of kids watching
can turn what they see
into a dream
and from a dream
into a real company.
You know, I started
my first company when I was 10,
so I definitely love
what you're doing.
The challenge is,
there's millions of kids
who might want to do
the same thing.
I don't know if you can
manage it all.
You haven't really taken it
to that point to demonstrate
that you can support them
outside of Denver.
And so, while I applaud you,
I have to say I'm out.
♪♪
Okay. Thank you so much
for your time.
Thank you, Jack.
Corcoran:
To the marketplace.
I think that's
the wrong road for you.
I think the lemonade stand,
kids are gonna learn.
It's easier, it's cheaper,
you're in, you're out,
and you don't have
an inventory issue.
I worry about
controlling the inventory,
keeping it staffed,
telling your stories.
It complicates it
times a hundred.
I'm out.
But a phenomenal job
here today.
A true inspiration.
Thank you so much.
Greiner:
Jack, you are amazing.
I cannot believe
how you came in here,
spoke so eloquently,
so sharp, so fearless,
and you're 10.
Blows me away.
Thank you.
But I think you should
grow very slowly.
Because you are 10
and you are in school,
I think that you should wait
till you're a little older
before you expand too much.
I wish you the best.
I'm out.
Thank you so much.
Sacca:
So, here's the thing.
There's no way I'm gonna let
the best pitch of the year
get out the door
without an offer there.
You said you're
financing some debt ‐‐
a couple‐hundred dollars
a month right now.
Jumping up to $50,000
is interesting.
So, here's what
I want to do, though.
I want to offer you
a $50,000 loan
at 2% interest.
But I've got some
conditions on it.
One is, you draw it down
$10,000 at a time.
And each time
you draw down a $10,000,
we wait a few months
and we see how you're doing ‐‐
if you're keeping up
on the payments,
is the business
is holding up.
And if it is, then you can
draw down another $10,000.
Okay.
Two is, I think you should
start a video podcast.
I think, whether it's
on a Youtube channel or
Facebook to Periscope...
That's a good idea.
... I think there's
a great opportunity
for you to share these lessons
with other entrepreneurs
and make some ad revenue
doing that.
O'Leary: Jack,
if you take that deal,
you'll be the most
in‐debt 9‐year‐old I know.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
We'd love
to take your deal.
Cuban: Congrats, Jack.
Good job.
‐Congrats.
‐Good move.
‐Thank you so much.
Congrats, buddy.
Thank you.
All right, good luck.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Thank you, guys.
Good job.
[ Applause ]
He's now $60,000 in debt.
He's 9 years old.
[ Laughter ]
Yes!
Yes.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Jack:
It was just awesome.
Just to get an offer
made my heart skip a beat.
But even though
Mr. Wonderful said
that I was the most in‐debt
10‐year‐old in America,
I will pay all of my debt back
by growing the business.
♪♪
My name is Jae Kim,
and I live in Austin, Texas.
I was born and raised
in South Korea.
When I was 11 years old,
my mom decided to bring
my sister and I to United States
to live a new life.
Soy, kimchi fries,
and some more tacos, guys.
Korean food is passion for me.
I graduated from college.
I didn't have the money
to start a restaurant,
so I decided to start
a food‐truck business.
Hi.
Our food truck was so popular
that we've grown
to a fleet of food trucks
and three restaurants.
Enjoy.
We're serving Korean barbecue
in a way that people
can eat every day.
Hi, Jae.
We miss you.
I owe everything to my mom.
She taught me to never give up.
I applied to "Shark Tank"
four years ago, and no luck.
I applied second time ‐‐
no chance.
This time, I have a fleet
of food trucks and restaurants.
This is my big opportunity,
and I don't want to blow it.
♪♪
Yes!
It's so great
to finally be here.
My name is Jae Kim.
I'm the founder and CEO
of Chi'lantro BBQ
in Austin, Texas.
I'm seeking $600,000
for 15% of my business.
It's taken me a while
to be in front of you today.
Four years ago,
I tried with one food truck.
Any luck?
Nope.
Two years after,
I tried again with
five food trucks this time.
Any love?
Nope, no love.
[ Chuckles ]
And today, I have
a full fleet of food trucks
and three
fast‐casual restaurants
that are extremely successful,
and two more on the way.
I envision Chi'lantro empire.
Chris,
I'd love to invite you,
because I know that you've
invested in restaurants.
So, could you make
Korean barbecue bowl with me?
Let's do it.
Kim: Thank you.
Just come right this way.
You don't have to ask me
twice for Korean barbecue.
All right.
You know me well ‐‐
we're starting
with the carbs.
Absolutely. We have brown rice,
white rice, and noodles.
Let's so white rice.
All right, let's do it.
All right, and we have
Korean barbecue next ‐‐
soy‐glazed chicken,
Korean barbecue beef,
and spicy pork.
You tell me.
I'd say
Korean barbecue beef.
We have all the veggies
on the side...
Mm‐hmm.
... so I would add
some fresh veggies.
Lettuce, carrots,
purple cabbage,
some cilantro,
and onions.
Oh, but wait,
it gets better.
It gets better.
We have some ‐‐
the original kimchi fries.
‐Fries!
‐Right.
All right,
and this is for you.
And we have some signature
sauces on the side
for you to try.
See, it pays to be
the most handsome Shark.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
‐Thank you.
‐Enjoy.
Can I ask what
the sauces are here?
‐Yeah, absolutely.
‐These look interesting.
Absolutely.
It's our magic sauce.
‐Yum!
‐Thank you very much
Magic sauce.
There you go, Mark.
Enjoy.
Thank you, sir.
Appreciate it, Jae.
This has
zero calories, right?
Uh...
Okay,
what are we eating?
What you have in front of you
are two of my favorite dishes ‐‐
Korean barbecue bowl
and the other
is the original kimchi fries
topped with Korean barbecue,
caramelized kimchi,
and our special magic sauce.
Where are you from?
I grew up in Korea.
My mom is divorced,
so we came to the States.
And it was really hard for us
to be growing up...
You know, for me,
I really really needed to,
you know, step up
and really help out the family.
And my first business
was when I was 21.
I ran a coffee shop.
So, I worked there
every single day
while paying for
my college tuition
and going to school.
And, obviously, having
the first business, I failed.
Why do you think
it failed?
I didn't have a vision
for the business,
so I just worked
every single day
just to pay the bills.
And when
it came down to it,
I just didn't see
where I could take this.
So, I called it quits.
But afterwards, I just
started thinking about,
"I could have
done this differently,"
and that really
fired me up.
When I first started
this business,
I had $30,000 in savings,
and I maxed out my credit card
just to survive for six months.
No, but you know what,
that says something.
You started
your coffee shop.
Yes.
You paid
for your college,
and you managed
to save $30,000.
That's right.
Let me just tell you,
every day, people give me
E‐mails saying,
"Oh, my goodness,
I need to borrow money.
Oh, my goodness, I need
to go out and raise money."
And they always say,
"What's the best way?"
And I always say, "Save."
Right?
And you're just
the perfect example of that.
If you bust your ass and you
cut your costs, you can save.
And so bravo, man.
Thank you.
‐That is awesome.
‐Thank you, Mark, so much.
That's the American Dream
right there.
The food was fantastic.
Really good.
I like the fresh elements to it.
I can see why it sells.
Let's get into the numbers
a little bit.
Last year,
we did $4.7 million.
Yeah!
$4.7 million.
That's badass.
How much from the trucks?
Food trucks are around
$300,000 to $400,000.
Restaurants are doing
about $1 million to
$1.5 million per unit.
We've maximized our growth.
But it really comes down to,
you know,
I need more money
to really grow.
Hey, Jae,
can we take a step back?
Sure.
Now that
I'm catching my breath,
that's some of the best food
I've ever eaten.
‐Thank you, Chris.
‐It's absolutely delicious.
And I can see why
you've had this success.
So, are you gonna hit
$5 million‐plus sales next year?
Yes, we're gonna be
doing $6 million this year.
So, you have actually
lived the American Dream
and every essence of it.
‐Amen.
‐Mm‐hmm.
I try my best.
How many restaurants,
how many trucks
do you want to have?
My goal is 15 restaurants
doing $15 million in revenue.
Jae, I've invested
in a number of restaurants.
I think our most well‐known
is "Veggie Grill."
But when we invest
in those restaurants,
we're not
the growth capital.
We're the people who are helping
them in the early days
try and completely
change the game.
We're bringing
plant‐based food affordably.
And really delicious food
to a brand‐new audience
was what got us
into that deal,
not helping them scale from
20 locations to 50 to 100.
You're kicking a lot of ass,
and it's absolutely delicious.
But, you haven't told me
what you are uniquely doing
to change the landscape
for everybody else.
And so, as they say, if it's
not a "hell yes," it's a no.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Thank you, Chris.
My challenge
with your deal, Jae,
is having invested
in restaurants in the past
and not having
a good outcome as a result,
it's made me
a little more skeptical
about that part
of your business.
So, when you open
a new restaurant,
if the location doesn't work
for any reason,
you can't just move it.
You have a lease, you've got
a lot of capital tied up.
I don't like
that part of your deal.
For that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Jae, you're
a shining‐light example
for every entrepreneur
watching.
This is the way
you do it.
Brains are always a whole lot
more valuable than cash.
Food was beyond spectacular.
I love it.
I'm just not
a restaurant guy.
I get pitched restaurants
every day.
In order to do them right,
to be anything other
than dumb capital,
you've got to be there
helping side‐by‐side.
And that's just not
a fit for me right now.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I am a fan
of Korean barbecue,
and this is the best
I've ever had.
I think
that this is great,
but I don't see it
as a good investment for me.
I'm a little bit leery
about your model of growing.
Sometimes, I think it's better
if you really get a good hold
on what you're doing
before you expand it too fast.
So I'm out,
but I love it.
Thank you.
Okay, Jae,
four Sharks are out.
What are you
gonna do, Barbara?
I've learned that people
that start a food business,
if they're any good
and worth their salt,
that they're very good people
in their soul.
Because you're serving food
to people,
and that takes a certain type
of entrepreneur, right?
I have one investment
in Tom + Chee.
That started out
with $1.2 million
when they were
in "Shark Tank,"
and they were
a baby business,
but at least had
one truck, two shops.
And now they're doing
$51 million in sales.
I'm your ideal partner
because I know exactly
the structure problems
they had in developing
their business.
I know the obstacles
they jumped over.
I know how to franchise,
how not to franchise,
and I think this is
a franchise play.
I have an offer for you.
And I could actually
take more advantage
and be more aggressive,
'cause none of the other Sharks
are interested.
Barbara, if you get greedy,
I'll jump back in.
I'm gonna offer you $600,000
for 30% of your business.
‐Ouch.
‐Whoa.
But what
I don't want you to do
is judge me
as a financial partner,
because I'm a heck of a lot more
than that.
I'm really savvy
in your space.
And whatever
your dreams are
over the next
three‐to‐five years,
I have no doubt in my mind
that I could
get you there really fast
without making
a lot of mistakes.
So, Barbara,
thank you for the offer.
I really appreciate it.
We're profiting at
a 15% profit margin,
which means I'm able to pay you
back a lot more faster
in case that this wasn't
a good deal for you.
So, 30% is a lot
of a percentage.
Would you consider
coming down to 20%?
You got yourself a deal.
It's a fair deal.
‐Yeah!
‐Wow.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations.
You are a straight shooter.
I'm crazy about you.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I'm leaping to you,
baby.
‐Aw.
‐Oh.
Oh, my gosh!
Ah!
Look what happened!
‐I'm sorry.
‐You're disgusting!
I'm sorry!
[ Laughter ]
Oh,
I'm sorry about that.
‐I'm very happy about it.
‐Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
‐Congrats, Jae.
‐Thanks, guys.
Cheers on all your success.
It's inspiring.
Whoo!
I do what I do for my mom
and my sister.
[ Voice breaking ]
So, it's important for me...
to make sure that I'm there
for them, you know?
That I do my best.
That ‐‐ That ‐‐ That
I don't give up.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a technology
to make house hunting
more convenient.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Junior,
and I'm from the Big "D" ‐‐
Dallas, Texas.
‐What!
‐Yeah.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm here seeking $500,000 in
exchange for 10% equity stake
in my business, Toor.
As you know, buying a home
should be fun and exciting,
especially if you're
touring with Barbara.
But for the rest of us,
not so much.
It's time‐consuming
and frustrating.
Imagine ‐‐ You're
driving down the street,
trying to look for
that perfect property,
and you spot one.
Now what?
You can call an agent and
wait days for an appointment,
or, even worse,
wait weeks for an open house.
Wouldn't it be great
if you could tour
that property right there,
on the spot?
Well, thanks to me, you can.
[ Scattered chuckles ]
I'd like to introduce you
to Toor,
the world's smartest lockbox.
Toor is the first lockbox
that allows
buyers and sellers
to access the lockbox
with or without an agent.
Wow.
Barbara, I know
you've opened some doors
in your career.
I'd love some help.
Sure.
Thank you, dear.
Thank you.
Desinor: So, imagine Barbara's
driving down a street
and she sees
a property for sale.
She pulls it up
on the Toor app.
She immediately
sends a request.
The seller
approves her showing,
and immediately, Barbara
is able to tour the property.
So, Barbara,
simply walk up to the box.
Mm‐hmm, okay.
Press the power button
until you see that color wheel.
Okay, now simply
press "open" on the app.
Okay, easy enough.
There you go.
That's the coolest part!
Now the lockbox opens up.
Okay.
That's the coolest part.
She'll grab the keys,
tour the property on her own
or with a Realtor.
Feel like a winner.
Now, once your done, put
the keys back in the lockbox.
Okey dokey.
And simply press "close"
on the app.
There you go.
Give it a second,
and it will close right up.
The seller gets
a notification
saying Barbara's
completed her tour,
and now Barbara can
leave feedback
and be on her way.
Thank you so much.
Nice handshake.
Thank you.
‐Nice suit.
‐Thank you.
Desinor: So, Sharks, which one
of you guys wants to join me
in opening this door
to opportunity?
O'Leary: Junior,
while it's fresh on my mind...
Yes.
... what happens if the person
who just did the tour
does not redeposit the key,
but closes it anyways?
If that key is removed
for a set period of time
that you,
the seller, sets,
you get a notification
if that key is not put back.
Greiner:
But if it were my home,
I'm not sure I would want
somebody to go in unescorted.
Great question.
So, the beauty of our product
is that you, the seller ‐‐
you get to determine
what type of showing
you want in your house.
So, if you want
an agent present,
you simply require
an agent present.
That's very cool,
because, normally,
you have to wait...
Absolutely.
... you have
to find somebody,
that have to go get a key
back at the office.
You got it, you got it,
you got it.
Junior, numbers.
How much have you sold?
Yeah, so, zero.
‐Zero?
‐Zero sales.
Junior,
you're killing me!
It's 'cause we're brand‐new.
But, fortunately, we had a ‐‐
Do you want your punishment
now or later?
No, no, no, later.
Later.
Wait, hear me out.
Hear me out.
So, fortunately, we had a
successful Kickstarter campaign.
We actually sold over 800 boxes,
raising over $100,000.
‐Amazing.
‐Wow.
So, we have over
$100,000 in pre‐sales.
How much are you
selling them for?
So, the lockbox itself
is $199.
What does it cost you
to make them?
$50, and then $75 delivered
to the customer.
I'm very curious
what your background is.
I'm a real‐estate broker.
You sound like
a real‐estate broker.
[ Laughs ]
Sure does!
I flipped my first house
when I was 18 years old.
When I was at college
at Texas Tech,
I was president
of the real‐estate organization.
Were you really?
Why is it that you like
real estate so much?
Great question.
So, my parents are from Haiti.
They worked hard to put me
in a very nice private school.
All my best friends lived
in literally the nicest ‐‐
Mark Cuban's neighborhood,
to be exact.
Ever since I saw
these big houses,
I fell in love
with real estate.
Okay, Junior,
Defend your $5 million ‐‐
Before you get
to that ‐‐
Let me let it roll off
my lips ‐‐ $5 million.
How much money have you
invested in this, Junior.
I'm not gonna stop,
I don't know why ‐‐
Kevin, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Tell me why it's worth
$5 million.
Here's how we make money.
We charge a monitoring fee
for these lockboxes.
How much
is the monthly?
$100 a month.
‐Ooh.
‐Wow! What?
That's a lot of money.
Nooo, guys.
Barbara, please, educate
these guys on how much...
[ Laughter ]
...Realtors spend
every month, guys.
It strikes me
as a lot of money.
Look, last Saturday, I visited
15 homes in a day ‐‐
each with
an electronic lockbox on it.
Right.
The agents just
held their phone up.
That's it. You got it.
With Bluetooth,
they get in.
So, these devices
exist already.
Yeah, but ‐‐
So you have one
incremental change on that,
which is an interface
where a user can say,
"Yes, I'll let people in when
there isn't an agent there."
That's the only thing that
you're doing that's different.
No. No, no, no.
Tell me what's ‐‐
What's different?
Here's what's ‐‐
I mean,
I literally used this ‐‐
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Give him a chance, cowboy.
Calm down.
You had to wait on that agent
to let you in, right?
Yeah. So, the only thing
you have different
is the interface that
lets the seller say...
That's a big difference.
... go ahead an open it up.
No!
Chris, imagine ‐‐
It's a big difference,
but that's not necessarily
defensible.
‐Calm down, calm down.
‐Let him talk.
Imagine if you could
see five properties in
one day on your own,
as opposed
to calling your agent,
the agent calls
the showing company,
the showing company calls
the listing agent...
Look, Junior, Junior, I ‐‐
...the listing agent calls
the seller,
the seller confirms it.
That's right.
They go back
to the listing agent,
The listing agent calls
the showing company,
the showing company then
confirms with the buying agent.
Junior, nobody hates
wasting time more than I do.
But why can't the company
that already has
massive market share
do exactly this?
If you look at
the incumbents in our industry,
they're old, they're dated.
Their technology's old.
They have no platform.
They're so disconnected
from Realtors today.
Anyone in real‐estate ‐‐
You can't convince me
that somebody
who actually has
a smart lockbox
operated by Bluetooth
is old and disconnected.
I mean, it's, like,
two‐year‐old technology.
But there's way‐‐
our platform is more
than just a lockbox.
Literally,
the verification part
of what you're doing
is the easiest part.
So, what is, would you say,
your secret sauce?
I don't know if you have
any IP on this, or what.
‐We do, we do.
‐What is that?
We're patent pending ‐‐
the ability to open and close
the lockbox mechanically
without physically closing,
which enables our remote
opening and closing.
And no one else
can do that?
‐You got it.
‐What?
Correct.
No, that technology
exists today!
No, not on a lockbox.
Absolutely not.
Where have you seen
a real ‐‐
You're absolutely
kidding me.
There is not
a single lockbox out there
that can close on its own.
You know what,
don't be so arrogant.
I'm not so arrogant.
I just know this space,
and I'm sitting here
watching somebody tell us
that this dated technology
isn't what it is.
So, what lockbox
can close on its own?
[ Stammers ]
So, let me see
if I get this.
Hold on.
My God.
Let me see if I get this.
And poor Chris is having
his disconnect.
[ Laughing ] Chris.
When Chris went
to look at 15 homes,
how did you schedule
those 15?
We had an agent take us
to half of them.
I saw half on my own.
No, no,
that's not what I asked.
That's not what I asked.
How did you schedule them?
You made a plan to go see
15 homes in a development.
Yeah.
Some of us grew up ‐‐
when we dreamed and aspired
to buy a house...
Oh, geez. Should we get
the violin music out?
Just listen.
Listen.
O'Leary: Junior, you've got
the Sharks arguing
about your business model.
Beautiful.
Now, we happen
to have Barbara.
You're
Miss Real Estate here.
Are you gonna give
this guy $500,000?
Corcoran: It's a tough call.
He's entirely right.
It clearly
answers a need,
and you're not gonna
get any innovation
out of the old guys
in the industry.
They would have invented
it a long time ago.
They're asleep
at the wheel.
They don't want the change
because they own the market.
Right.
Secondly,
you are probably
one of the best salespeople
I've ever seen in my life.
Barbara, thank you.
I mean, not only do you
know your stuff,
you kind of leveled
the playing field
with this Daddy Warbucks
at the end,
wearing
the fake cowboy shirt.
Greiner: Well, listen.
I like when people create
better mousetraps,
and this is
a better mousetrap, obviously,
for your application.
But my problem here today
is just that it's
really, really early.
Mm‐hmm.
So, because you're not
ready yet, I'm out.
Thank you so much for your time.
I appreciate it.
O'Leary:
Junior, everybody agrees
you're a great salesman.
Thank you, Kevin.
So, the problem is,
you blew it
by asking for $500,000
in the prototype stage.
It's too much risk.
However,
I'd like to be invested
in a damn‐good sales guy.
I'm gonna structure
a deal this way.
I'll give you the $500,000
in two components.
A hunsky ‐‐ $100,000 ‐‐ and
I get the 10% equity for that.
Then I loan you $400,000.
I'm gonna charge you
18% for that,
which is what you would
pay in the market.
Would you like
to take that offer?
Does that
make sense to you?
Uh, I'd like
to consider the offer.
You've got to make
a decision.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Junior has one offer
on the table from Kevin ‐‐
$500,000 for a 10% stake,
but $400,000 of it
as a loan at 18% interest
for his smart‐lockbox company,
Toor.
Would you like
to take that offer?
Does does that
make sense to you?
Uh, I'd like
to consider the offer.
I'd like to hear from my guys
on the end here.
Junior,
I'll save you some time.
If I knew the real‐estate
business at all...
Right.
...I would do
something with you.
I just don't see a path
where I can say,
"I can help you get
from here to here."
As much as I hate to say it,
I'm out.
‐Thank you, Mark.
‐You're welcome.
So, Barbara, my dear.
Junior, I'd like
to join Kevin on his offer.
But I need to have
a contingency,
because it's
enormously high‐risk.
Okay.
It's contingent that we can
sell it to a giant chain
to buy a ton
of these lockboxes.
O'Leary: And we'll both
help you do that.
It's nothing but calling
all the heads of these firms,
all right, allowing you to make
your sales presentation.
You're the best salesman
we've ever met.
[ Chuckles ]
We'll just get
the door open for you.
I still haven't had
a chance to go out.
And you're not.
Let's save the best for last.
Whoa,
be careful, though.
‐Got to be careful. Don't ‐‐
‐Be careful.
But I think
you were testing me.
I feel like
the very best products
and the very best
entrepreneurs
are the ones worth
arguing with, right?
That's what's led
to the creation
of the greatest
companies ever.
Backpedaling
like the sucker you are.
No, because that means
we're both emotionally
invested in something.
That's right.
We both care about this.
I'm torn. You're one
of the greatest salespeople
I've ever seen,
but this is an idea
that I think
is looking backwards.
Let's be honest.
Keys are going away.
Not today.
Not today,
but here's the thing.
I don't want
a better mousetrap.
I want a bear trap
that's gonna be around
in 10, 15, 20 years ‐‐
A big public company
worth billions of dollars.
These guys like
the short term ‐‐
the two‐year,
three‐year cash flow.
Junior, kick his heinie
back to the Valley.
So, look, look,
here's the thing, man.
Prove me wrong,
make me pay 10 times more
for it next year,
but today, I'm out.
Ah,
that's sad to hear, Chris.
Kevin, to have you
as a partner,
Barbara, to have a partner
in the real‐estate industry,
obviously would be
a no‐brainer.
Here's what
I would counter you ‐‐
$250,000 for 10%,
and a $250,000 line of credit.
♪♪
Can we step
into the hall?
Yes, yes, if you'd like.
[ Chuckles ]
Okay, we'll do $200,000
for the 10%,
$300,000 loan.
♪♪
‐Deal.
‐Okay.
‐Good job, guys.
You're a good salesman.
Thank you, my man.
Barbara, my dear.
My dear.
And I want to discuss it
over dinner tonight.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Desinor:
It was brutal in there,
but I'm super thrilled
about my partners.
I'm ready to get to work.
You know, you make a good point,
it's old tech.
But there's a ton
of old tech in real estate,
'cause it's
so sleepy valley.
I've already seen
the new tech out there.
It's there.
I used it last week.
No, no, that's not true,
and that's deliberate.
What do you mean,
it's deliberate?
That's denigrating
to him, Chris,
because the key
isn't the software.
The software's
the easiest part.
No, no, no.
Like, Mark, you're not making
any sense at all, man.
I'm making total sense!
No, no, no. You're not.
Where ‐‐ no, no...
How stupid are you?
How is he making you aware
of that place?
I know this is
going over your head.
No, it's not, Mark.
Do you think people drive down
the street and look for houses?
They see their dream home,
they see a "For Sale" sign,
they'd love to get in.
You don't understand, Mark.
‐And what do they do?
Mark,
the device exists today.
It lets you in by Bluetooth
from your phone.
Not in that circumstance.
With one new line of code,
it can let in anyone.
So, in your example,
I drive by,
and I want it now ‐‐
right now.
Uh‐huh, yep.
Right now, who do I call?
So, you ping in the ‐‐
no, look, look, look.
With the existing ‐‐
Exactly.
‐Hold on.
‐Exactly.
Shut up and listen.
Don't be mad at me
that I understand this
better than you do.
[ Scoffs ]
Look, you're saying
he's got some special way
of getting me in the house
immediately?
No!
No, no, no!
Then they're already
ahead of him.
They have exactly that.
You have to go through
the agent to get...
Listen!
No, you don't.
Guys, guys, agree for
the Sharks to disagree.
Like how any agent
gets into a house
with the other
technology.
They walk up ‐‐ boom ‐‐
they're in the house.
So what you're saying ‐‐
what the agents do,
you can enable
for the consumer to do.
‐Absolutely.
‐Right, I get that.
Hey, thanks for catching up.
I appreciate it.
Except if you're not
using the agent,
you don't want
to call the agent,
and you want
to make it available...
Corcoran: Right now.
... so that the keys
are right there
and somebody who's comfortable
with keys can use it.
But he can't do that.
Yes, he can!
He doesn't have
a natural advantage there.
Hey, why don't
we agree to disagree?
So, why are
a million lockboxes ‐‐
the traditional
lockboxes ‐‐
why are a million of them
sold a year?
And why does
the other company
have millions of dollars
worth of sales already,
doing exactly this?
All they have to do
is flip one bit and
expand their audience,
and they win.
How do you connect
those boxes?
Good luck, guys.
I wish you luck
getting your money back.
Have a seat, Chris.
We all agree we disagree.
No,
you got it wrong, Chris.
I sometimes wonder how you
made all that money, Mark.
♪♪